[Music]  hey  [Music]  you took my money away  you said that it was safe but i'm robbed  and i don't feel okay  i trusted you you said that it was all  right  oh but now i'm broke  [Music]  i got greedy now my friends all make fun  of me  [Music]  cause all coins that i thought were  clean are now dirty  [Music]  they promise you the food but i'm burned  up and re-entry  oh hey  [Music]  you took my money away  you said that it was safe but i'm robbed  and i don't feel okay  i trusted you you said that it was all  right  oh but now i'm broke and my wallet  [Music]  devs have been gone for three years but  the boys they ain't selling  [Music]  it was the top  [Applause]  [Music]  hey you took my money away  you said that it was safe but i'm robbed  and i don't feel okay  i trusted you you said that it was all  right  oh but now i'm broke and my wallet